[Music]
foreign
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you
eating ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony them
[Music]
Another One Bites the Dust
Mark Meadows subpoenaed by Jack Smith
Mike Pence is gonna fight it
will we see Mark Meadows Fight The
subpoena
to save his own ass okay here's the
thing and because we're talking about
the Mike's Pence subpoena we also we
also talked about
um we also talked
about Mike Pence yesterday but we're
going to talk about Mark Meadows today
but my my take on this is is that
they're they're gonna fight this to the
Supreme Court they're gonna lose
there's no way they're gonna win this
argument
um of the Mike Pence's argument
specifically but I'm sure Mark Meadows
will do the same thing the problem is is
Mark Meadows actually has a referral
from Congress to the Department of
Justice for criminal contempt of
congress so
um oh boy he has a pattern and you can
actually try to defy a congressional
subpoena you can do that sometimes it's
criminal in the case of Steve Bannon
Navarro Meadows you know and the like
they can refer a criminal referral to
Department of Justice for contempt of
congress for not
um
giving this opinion following the
subpoena
on a grand jury a criminal grand jury
specifically it's a little more
complicated than that you you must do
that
um otherwise you become a Target
are you you become a Target
when a grand jury subpoenas you for your
testimony in a criminal case generally
that the grand jury is not looking for
the person that they're looking to
indict
right so the indication is because Mark
Meadows and Mike Pence is going to be
subpoenaed and going to appear
no matter what their battle is I mean
unless they want to you know get cop
another criminal charge uh to not
um
to actually go for the subpoena but but
here's here's
here's the point
I am all for this I am all for them
fighting for this I am all for Mike
Pence going to Supreme Court
we know he's gonna lose
that fight
um this Supreme Court even is is shitty
and and trumped up as it is
the Supreme Court has already stopped
the idea that you cannot that you can
use these speech and debate clause in
Mike Pence's case
to subvert a subpoena we saw this with
the Fannie Willis Case down in Georgia
with Lindsey Graham Lindsey Graham tried
this do you remember do you remember who
lady G is do you remember how he tried
to subvert our Constitution and overturn
our election down in Georgia
our free and fair election
do you remember this and he had to go I
don't know appear before a grand jury
which there's news on that today as well
it looks like people are going to get
indicted
um I'm getting news here and I don't
know if it's news I can say
someone's giving you some breaking news
and I don't know if it's uh and it has
to do with
oh all these Republicans legal woes but
I don't even know if I can say it at
this point here
oh my god listen
if Mike Pence uh delays this process of
the subpoena for the grand jury and the
special counsel the criminal grand jury
um in the criminal investigation of
January 6 and remember Jack Smith is
also
he's also
um investigating the documents case
which folks is the same exact case the
case against Trump and his closest
allies who tried to overturn our
election and on our constitution
it's the same case with the documents
okay it's the same like
there's other crimes I mean there's
always more crime that's you know
adjacent to the crime that Trump's
committing right now right I mean you
know it's kind of like a bull in the
chain cab just knock all the crimes over
at once
but the the January 6 case in the
documents case I believe in my opinion
and Meyer Garland only proved it by
handing both to Jack Smith
is that they're one in the same case
now maybe the Department of Justice
didn't know that at first maybe they
weren't 100 for sure that it was the
exact same case once they collected that
evidence with the search warrant I I
believe they came to conclusion that
these are the same
he was stealing documents to cover up
his coup attempt
Joe Biden didn't put uh coup attempt
documents next to the Corvette I don't
think Mike Pence had coup attempt
documents at his house in Indiana I
don't believe that there's no indication
of that none no indication
but Mike Pence stalling this subpoena
is good for politics folks
again I laid out the timeline for you
yesterday
now I don't believe that uh Mike Pence's
testimony is
is going to provide any more evidence
what Jack Smith needs then the evidence
that he has he's just trying to
collaborate as much evidence as he
possibly can for the grand jury to make
those decisions in those indictments
right
so he's presenting evidence as we go
along
and here we have just within a couple
days we have the former vice president
whose task in the coup attempt it was
to accept fraudulent electors
think about this think about this the
whole point
of the coup attempt with the with the
fake elector scheme was Mike Pence to
stall
so that they could swap them
right
they could pull the old Switcheroo
because this idea that you were gonna
throw it back to the States and stall it
for days and days on end and the states
were going to come back with a different
conclusion as bone-headed and
the reason why it's boneheaded is
because of Georgia and Arizona okay
there was a republican governor and a
republican Secretary of State in air in
in Georgia
and we know this by the phone
call that we're refused to go along with
the LIE refused to commit voter
fraud and election fraud
for Trump we know this we know they were
unwilling to do that in Georgia so what
would make them think
that stalling for a few more days would
change
the governor's mind to uncertify the
results which in Georgia the governor
signs the certification
the same way in Arizona
it was a republican Secretary of State a
Republican governor
who signed a certification we it's not
difficult we even watched Rusty Bowers
the Republican speaker of Arizona
sit in front of the January 6th select
committee and said yeah I mean I I would
go along with the idea if they had
evidence but it was a lie it was a it
was a lie and I can't I can't
steal the election based on fraud is I
in all intensive words what Rusty Bowers
said and then he said well yeah I'd vote
for Donald Trump again you goddamn Rider
vote for that guy he's the best
Republican ever
it's I know it doesn't make a lot of
sense and we live in a weird
timeline
but there was no chance that stalling
was going to change the state's Minds
what they wanted to do was polio
switcheroo
on the fake collectors that's what that
was the goal to create confusion create
violence create a situation where they
you remember the picture
and I believe we Breeze over this image
so far too often
that day of January 6.
when those maggots
tried to overturn our government at the
behest of the Cheeto dusk q and honor
because he said so and he wanted to be
dictator
and he was such a loser such a
whiny little a ass
ass
I'm kidding to turn around I I
don't know
maybe he is a bitch-ass or a
ass either way either way you
shake it
he was so so
hurt that he lost
that he had to sell them a big line
grift money on the big lie and then
convince them to go overturn the
government for him
the image
of the women
who had the wherewithal
and the fortitude to know
that those electors that were in that
box were more than just symbolism
of our democracy they were more than
just symbolism
of our vote
of our Republic
of our ballots and our rights and our
freedom and our Liberty
that they knew instantly
to get that box far away
from anyone who could switch those
electors
who could somehow swap them so Mike
Pence could declare these fake electors
you think that's what we're gonna find
out
do you think do you think that's what
was hidden in some of those documents
do you think that's what's in some of
these emails and some of these
communications do you think that's what
Scott Perry you criminal is
trying to hide from the Department of
Justice on his cell phone
listen folks
if you're not aware how criminal
prosecutions work of non-presidents
it is being laid out very clearly
of what it looks like of former prisons
of the United States
and I don't think the United States
Constitution gives two shits
rather a former president committed
those crimes
before during or after they were present
which is clear
now as day
that Donald Trump did I mean Jesus
Christ his organization was charged and
found guilty of 17 counts of tax fraud
in the state of New York he's a criminal
folks he's a convicted criminal
maybe not him personally but he's
getting there
and Mike Pence stalling this action
only gives us that much more time
to create our narrative
to make sure our messaging is on point
to bury fascism once and for all
in the form of Maga and trumpism in this
country
I know you're sick and tired of
it
I know the rest of the country is sick
and tired of it you think people
who don't even pay to there's people
still excited about the Super Bowl who
won or who lost people on Philly are
pissed people around Kansas City
are excited still excited yesterday was
the parade in Kansas City
most those people don't even know who
the vice president is right now could
couldn't tell you
who the department
of Transportation secretaries couldn't
tell you who runs the dod
couldn't tell you who's a U.N ambassador
they couldn't tell you probably who is
the the lieutenant governor of
their state
but you know what they're sick and tired
of
they're sick and tired of this Trump
they're sick and tired of
the
yeah they might be trumpers they might
have voted for Trump but they're sick
and tired of hearing it
and we have to keep going
he have to make them so sick to their
stomachs
in support of him
we talked about it yesterday folks we
talked about yesterday that Democrats I
believe
Democrats that are in in power in blue
States should immediately right now
immediately be in front of microphones
talking about gerrymandering districts
and states I mean give a if it's
possible I don't give a
I don't care do you just start talking
about it talk about how they're gonna do
it don't give a how it's done they
shouldn't give a how it's done
start gerrymandering districts in blue
States
them em em em
what else we should do
we should start suppressing their vote
making them embarrassed
making them embarrassed to even go to a
Ballot Box
you know there was a time in this
country where religious people
religious people
didn't participate in politics because
politics was evil
it was unchristian-like
it wasn't for the faint of heart
they were Crux they were scumbags they
were Liars they were cheats they stole
it's politics
we should Institute that part of our
society back
where religious people decided to stay
the out of politics
and not participate self-suppression
yeah I'm saying it I'm saying it we
should let them self-suppress their vote
and we should form a national narrative
and a national message to shame them
into doing it I know these people don't
have shame I understand that I get it I
get it you're like Tony Jesus Christ
you're talking you're talking about
they do how do you think
that the real America First Nazi party
has any kind of power anywhere in this
country how do you think they do it
how do you think they do it you think
it's some magical wand that they
have
do you do you think that they have
policies and ideas that people want
that benefit the people that you think
the people voting for them are voting in
their own self-interest
you know they're not
and you know our democracy is on the
ropes
you know it
hell that's why you come here and listen
to me every day or you're terrified of
the you're terrified of the truth
and you come here to hate watch welcome
Don
I don't know if he's here today I'm not
really watching the chat I am going to
watch the chat today uh when I'm done
with my a-block rant here we'll go to
the chat maybe we'll take some questions
or something so uh be ready be ready
after the break
maybe we'll maybe we'll go to the chat
and we'll talk let's talk
but Mike Pence stalling this subpoena
I I know a lot of people want to get
frustrated about it but it excites the
out of me
think about if Mike Pence would have
just complied with the subpoena just
complied when in dittus did his
duty
gave his testimony
of why Trump's a Criminal
and how he committed it Pence knows it
and the reason why Pence knows it is
because Trump was asking Pence to commit
crimes
hello think think think think about it
Mike Pence struggled with the decision
to overturn our government
because he would end up committing
crimes
his attorneys they said it at the
January 6 select hearings his attorneys
were telling him hey dude you can't
do this
it's a crime he's wanting you
crime with him
so the minute Mike Pence goes in front
of a grand jury and gives them the
evidence
which I mean they already had the
it's just you know
they want to hear now the horse's mouth
and he says yeah yeah oh yeah he wanted
me to commit crime for sure he's a
criminal
this is why Mike Pence
is stalling
but the more Mike Pence stalls the more
we get to talk about it
that's right
do you think do you think americ Garland
really was trying to listen to me you
naysayers out there who don't think that
Trump is going to see any kind of
criminal prosecution or any kind of
criminal date you're like oh no mere
Gardens weak uh they're weak that's why
they haven't put him in prison yet yeah
you're a dumb listen
if that was the truth they would have
done exonerated him
they would have done did it
the only thing taking the sweet little
time that it has done is to form a
message around it and we have
and we continue to build a narrative
that the country is listening to why the
do you think I say when these
people who voted for Trump are sick and
tired of hearing about I'm not talking
about the cult members folks that's
signed who I'm talking I'm not talking
about the people who dress up in the
sweaters with Trump's face all over it
that that are Avid Watchers of Fox News
that is not who I'm talking
about I'm talking about white people who
don't pay attention to politics who
voted for him because of their
whiteness
and their daddy's a Republican and my
daddy's Daddy
I'm talking about those people
who have no clue about politics in this
country but they vote and they
voted for him because oh yeah he was a
good president everybody at work says so
everybody at work says he's a good
president and I'm white and he's white
so
that's why those are the people
I'm talking about these people are sick
and tired of hearing about Trump they're
sick of it
and we're gonna have to give them every
reason to do two things a stay
the at home or two that's
intentional all right a and two a stay
the at home are two
vote for Joe Biden in 2024. because
that's gonna that's gonna be their
choices
I know you think I'm nuts but it
is going to be Donald Trump as a
republican nominee doubt me on that just
you just doubt me you look at
this naked Nikki Haley launch
that went over like a wet fart in a
white thong didn't it just like I told
you it would
half the country's like who the is
Nikki Haley
and why do I give a about her if
she's running for president
Donald Trump will crush her De Santos
will crush that
he is gonna lay no one
any slack
in his skirt scorched Earth campaign
to make sure that he's the president
United States to protect his own ass
Jesus Christ just weeks ago he was
talking about how he wants to get away
get rid of the Constitution so he can be
the dictator and you don't think he's
gonna destroy Ron he is willing to
restore destroy the Constitution of the
United States and say it out loud
you don't think he's gonna destroy Ron
just get the out of here
anyone who thinks Rhonda Santos has a
shot in Hell against Donald Trump in
this primaries bone-headed and
doesn't know doesn't know their head
from their ass and if they're saying
that if they're saying Ron DeSantis
has a chance they're they are not and
have not been paying the attention
they're the reason those people giving
that commentary listen to me when I tell
you this listen to me if anyone giving
commentary thinks Nikki Haley Ron
DeSantis or any other Republican is is a
threat to our country because they're
going to be the Presidential nominee
they're the reason that commentator
liberal or not I don't give a
liberal or not that commentator is the
reason why Trump won until in in 2016.
that's why
they fundamentally do not understand
White America
they do not understand the fear of
losing White Privilege they don't
understand it they won't understand it
and it does it because it doesn't make
sense
it does not make sense but it doesn't
have to for these people to vote for
this fool it doesn't have to
make sense to you it doesn't even have
to make sense on paper really
they're voting for their whiteness
plain and simple I don't even give a
if it's someone who who is not
overtly racist they're voting for their
whiteness and the affiliation of white
supremacy he knows that Trump knows that
he's gonna win the primary he
ain't gonna quit he won't stop
he he still is bitching this morning
about the 2020 election being rigged
when there's not a shred of
evidence
it's 2023 folks we're two years
two years past that election over two
years
and he's still bitching about it you
think he's gonna give up on being the
nominee of president in the United
States for 2024. you're out of
your mind you are out of your mind
the only way Donald Trump gets out of
this race is he chokes on a
bucket of chicken or a cheeseburger
that's it
bottom line
and Mike Pence stalling Mike Pence
stalling is making it worse on Trump
it's making it worse on Trump because we
get to talk about this if Mike
Pence would have just complied with the
subpoena we wouldn't even hardly
know that it happened
and think of the narratives that we get
to spend over the months to come
as Mike Pence challenges us and loses
and loses and loses and loses all the
way up to the Supreme Court
you don't think these are gonna be
victories for democracy I I am ready for
Mike Pence to lose
over and over time and time again as my
time when it faces up to
democracy it loses
because liberal democracy is
strong
it's strength that's why it's still
around that's why it still exists were
you were you in history class when they
started to talk about the 1930s and the
1940s in Europe
and around the world
liberal democracy one
and there's a reason why it won
because it wasn't supposed to win
liberal democracy is the beacon of
strength in this world
Jesus Christ even the people of Ukraine
are willing to fight for their their
banged up corrupt little democracy that
they have even because it's just because
it's just a hint just the feeling
of maybe they'll be better maybe we can
do better maybe there's less corruption
in this democracy that we can force and
it's worth dying for
you think that just happens out of
nowhere you just think that's a flash in
the pan get the out of here with
that and you fascist out there you
fascist you Trump supporting
fascists out there you white
supremacists racist bigot
democracy is coming for you
democracy is coming for you baby because
you can't hide from the truth
and you can't hide from the people
that's what Liberty does
it frees the population
not change it to the ground and with
freedom a population can do a hell of a
lot
especially kick fascism right back
underneath this Rock
so good luck to Mike Pence good luck to
Mark Meadows good luck to you
good luck
in your quest to say Donald Trump's ass
once again possibly putting you at
criminal liability because of it
I'm here for it I'm here to talk about
it and I'm going to keep talking about
it and the longer they stall the more I
get to talk and the more I get to talk
the more you get to listen the more you
get to listen the more you talk the more
you talk those people out there
listen
that's the whole point
that's politics baby
there's two parts of politics in this
country I tell you every single time
there's government there's policy you
know you got to put serious policy
makers
in office to do the thing called
governing
and then there's Politics the elections
and that's what the we do
that's what we do that's the people's
job
so let's do our job let's kick their
ass and take their names
let's do it let's do it I am so excited
to have you here today and I'm excited
to hear the news of all the great
subpoenas and I I'm excited to hear this
report coming from Georgia who's going
to get criminally charged
it's like a game show every day
in this country
it's like the Republican the Republican
crime wheel you spin it to see who who's
subpoenaed next for a criminal
investigation let's do it
let's do it and you do it every single
weekday right here on YouTube Twitter
and twitch live Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific also simulcasting from
the minus touch Facebook page do not do
not forget
subscribe to the Tony Michaels podcast
here on YouTube and if you're on another
platform get your ass over here and
subscribe maybe check out the chat maybe
check out the chat I might be in the
chat after the break here also follow us
on Twitter at Tony Michaels pod you can
vote for bonehead of the week you know
what bone end of the week is oh you
don't here's what bone of the week is we
put out a poll every single week and you
vote you decide who is the bonehead of
the week
and my co-host Gabe Sanchez and I break
it down in the second hour on Friday
tomorrow we break down bonehead of the
week so make sure you go vote on Twitter
at Tony Michaels pod you can also vote
on YouTube on the community tab also do
not forget to download every single
episode of the Tony Michaels podcast on
Apple Spotify and Google and if you're
over on Facebook follow me at the Tony
Michaels
oh by the way I got something new I want
to show you I got something new I want
to show you it Surfs Up
merch go to store not the
tonymichaels.com that's store dot the
tonymichaels.com we got coffee mugs and
t-shirts I'm gonna be putting more items
up with this design on the store this
over the weekend and I promise you I
promise you
we are coming with the ass
45 the p-a-b-e 45 designs they are on
their way probably here sometime next
week
and we'll do the same thing we'll start
with like shirts and do some other
things see what you guys want oh and I'm
gonna put a hoodie up
our Canadian friends said hey it's cold
up here all the time put
they Surf's Up hoodie so
we're gonna do that I'll do that over
the weekend so stay tuned watch the
Twitter account watch the Community Feed
outputs and and if you're on patreon I'm
gonna I I send the news over there to
the patreon uh the members on patreon
first uh so if you're on patreon I try
to post everything there first so you
can see it and and if you want to check
out patreon do that for me we have a
Sunday rant I'll be ranting about
something this Sunday and I give you
early access to all the social media
videos I just put one out before I came
on the show about Mike Pence believe it
or not
so uh go check out patreon at
tonymichaels.com just click the patreon
link or go to patreon.com
the Tony Michaels don't go anywhere I'll
be right back right after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard in blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your part in blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show I think we're
gonna go to the chat what do you think
um
[Music]
Sanchez can't join us this morning he
had a another
so he won't be joining us don't get too
sad don't get too sad it's okay you have
me the Tony Michaels here as you do
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
every single one of them have I have I
missed the show ever I don't think I
have I mean we've taken a few days off
for holidays
and I think it was about a year ago
I think that you've been a year ago
about a year ago I lost my voice I had
sinus trouble well and that I had I had
sinus trouble here I don't know about a
month ago
almost lost my voice
I don't quit I don't stop I'm not going
dude and it's because of you it's
because of you is the reason why I keep
talking the reason why I keep yelling
and screaming the reason why I keep
ranting and I'm going to continue to do
it as long as I possibly can they want
to cart me out of here on a gurney
before I walk away from this microphone
and you are the reason so let's let's go
to the um let's go the chat see what we
got here does anyone have um oh um
Suzanne says loves the haircut thank you
very much I just got a haircut the other
day uh you know you got to get your
hairs cut every once in a while
and I'm I'm the same you gotta you gotta
get it a lot of people like the pardon
blanket commercial Joe from Facebook
says pardon blanket they're all gonna
need pardon blankets aren't they here's
what I'll tell you about that because
Joe that's actually
um not a bad point about the pardon
I doubt that Joe Biden would even
consider giving Donald Trump a pardon I
know James Comey said oh good Jim badden
should should think about serving his
country and making it easier by
pardoning down that that
I no not that no you don't pardon
traitors now
I actually believe that Joe Biden would
give consideration to someone like Mike
Pence consideration I don't think he'd
actually do it but he might Joe's a
decent guy he's a decent
right he's decent Uncle Joe he reaches
the bar of decency I think he might
consider like he would contemplate I
don't think he'd actually do it be like
him him and that fly
him
oh let's see do we have any questions in
the chat Now's the Time to ask him
because I'm sitting right here
um do
I think Mark Meadows is cooperating
um I I guess that depends on your
definition of cooperating
Mike Mark Meadows excuse me Mike Pence
Mark Mike Meadows
aren't they one of the same at this
point uh Mark Meadows is probably
cooperating to some extent or did
cooperate to some extent and here's why
the the evidence that you have for that
like in the public is Mark Meadows was
found in contempt of congress just like
Steve Bannon and Navarro now they were
charged by the Department of Justice
Mark Meadow has not been charged by the
Department of Justice
the thing is is Mark Meadows possibly
committed election fraud his for his own
ballot where him and his wife rented
some bum ass trailer uh to to as a
permanent residence to vote North
Carolina and they're really not
um and dare and so I believe they might
have some sway over him so at some
degree he's probably cooperating what we
have to remember is he's cooperating
through his attorneys
right and that's the reason why I would
imagine that Mark Meadows is going to
try to challenge this subpoena because
Mark Meadows and Mike Pence to some
degree have some criminal liability here
uh we know that from the January 6th
Select Committee hearing just just from
the evidence that's public there's a
possibility they have criminal liability
now
in the in the scope of Jack Smith's Pro
I'm no lawyer right this is all
just common sense in my actual knowledge
of the system okay
but in the in the guise of Jack Smith's
investigation as him being the
prosecutor he's operating as if he's in
his own attorney as United
States Attorney he's got his own office
they got all the power that they need
to subpoena and to run a criminal grand
jury to indict people for federal crimes
right
this isn't like
um the tis James Civil Trial this is not
like the the Georgia case the Georgia
grand jury not even close to the same
Jack Smith has way more power here way
more power
um so even if Mark Meadows and Mike
Pence realistically are cooperating
they're cooperating through their
attorneys
through a certain extent
but they're trying to protect themselves
from Criminal liability
because they do not want to be found
indicted and arraigned on charges
because they decided to cooperate with
the fullest extent that they possibly
could
is to wind themselves up being indicted
so do I think they're cooperating yes do
I think it's to the fullest extent that
they could absolutely not
they're Republicans they're scumbags and
so thank you for the question uh Cindy
let's see who else is in it
what else who else has it
um
do we have any more questions here in
the chat I'm trying to get in the chat
today Gabe's not joining us I figured we
do a little chant time now let's see
okay so um here's Brian on YouTube he
said so you're saying that Trump won't
be in jail before the election no he
will not be in jail before the election
he will be indicted
I believe he will be indicted but he
will not be locked away
um and the reason why the reason why is
because of how the process works okay
um a good example is well The Oath
Keepers in the proud boys trial right
proud boys are on trial now Oath Keepers
went through it just months ago but
think about the timing of that think
about the timing from the time that they
were actually
indicted
to the time of their trial
and think about all the evidence that
was gathered up to their indictment
right now The Oath Keepers case and the
proud boys case was pretty cut and dry
as far as sedition was concerned they
provided a lot of evidence
and they were quick in the chain meaning
meaning Stuart Rhodes wasn't The
Mastermind behind the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup he wasn't at the top of
the rung on the ladder right
he was somewhere down you know mid
middle
of the rung in the latter scale
so the evidence led to Stuart Rhodes and
Enrique tario the proud boys and the
oathkeepers much quicker
because they were there on the ground at
the Capitol and that's where the
Department of Justice really started to
dig into the evidence of who are these
people why were they there why were they
trying to overthrow
were they just in the crowd and got
hyped up and went and committed federal
crimes and didn't know it were they part
of planning for a coup attempt is there
a coup and then they have to work to
that point
I mean just because we know that Donald
Trump wanted to be dictator and King
and he wanted and he wanted Mike Pence
to overturn the Constitution for him and
so he could on it and get rid of it
that way he could be dictator and King
of the United States of Maga
the reason why just because we know that
and it's very clear out in the open
doesn't mean that the Department of
Justice doesn't doesn't have to prove it
they have to prove that
and and we should expect them to prove
it we should expect that of them we do
not want them to lock away people
without evidence Jesus Christ that's
what they do with black people all over
this country that's not what we want
we do not want that
we want the Department of Justice to
have a high bar to lock away someone
they should have to have
evidence they should have to present a
case they should have to get a jury to
say yeah that's pretty cut and dry to me
and they did with the Oath Keepers
they're they're working on it with the
brown boys
but look at the timeline of that Brian
look at the timeline of how long it took
from January 6 when they start
investigating the people that were on
the ground that day during the violent
Insurrection The Oath Keepers and the
proud boys were there
and we're just now at their trial I mean
Stuart Rhodes hasn't even been sentenced
so think about the timeline
of them working all the way up the
ladder and and they're still
investigating Mike Pence Mark Meadows
Eastman Donald Trump his attorneys Jesus
Christ Jack Smith is asking for the crud
or excuse me the crime fraud the crud
the crime fraud exemption
from attorney client privilege that a
judge is likely to give him
just like the judge out in California
gave the crime and fraud exemption for
John Eastman's emails
because there was crime in it
you you can't you can't hide crime under
the guise of attorney-client privilege
it's not a thing you cannot hide crime
Mike Pence under the Guides of the
speech and debate clause it's not a
thing
it's not a thing they've already tried
it Lindsey Graham tried it Lindsey
Graham tried to hide Trump's crimes with
the speech and debate clause with the
information he knew because he was
subpoenaed in Georgia and they told him
to go himself
you can't do that you can't hide crime
no matter what it is you can't use an
excuse so the timeline Brian the
timeline is is that I believe he will be
indicted
but I also believe this
in all reality he will have won several
primaries by the time his trial is even
scheduled meaning by time they arraign
him get him in court he stalls a bunch
of times because that's what
he's it's what he does that's what
they'll do that's what they've tried to
do
by the time he does that and he wins a
few because he's going to win primaries
folks he's going to win him you
just hide and watch you doubt me just
doubt me he's gonna win these
primaries
and when he gets several primaries under
his belt he's going to be able to say
hey judge I'm actually the the likely
nominee for president United States
and I I would almost bet that a federal
judge is going to say you know what
you're right
it we'll kick it past we'll kick
your trial in the 2025.
I I think that's what's gonna happen I
know it's disappointing to hear that I
think that's what's going to happen
that's why our messaging and our
narrative is so important
because who gives a what the
Department of Justice and Jack Smith
does really
we're the ones who get to indict him in
2024 we're the ones we're the ones who
get to send that packing in
2024 we're the jury in 2024 folks we are
the jury us the people with our ballots
are the jury for Donald Trump and every
single Republican who will still support
him in that moment and they all will
every last one of them are going
to support him
all of them
there isn't going to be one of them
that's not going to support him
foreign
Scorch them
um let's see here
uh Janet says did you see that Trump got
a subpoena from the problem no I have
not seen that speaking of the bravoy's
case I have not said oh but oh baby I'd
love to see that Sabina no I mean uh
again these legal troubles for Trump are
not going away that's why I'm excited
about the next 18 months folks
he's gonna be their nominee and he's
gonna be criminally charged and he's
gonna have a ton of legal problems
the other thing he's gonna have he's
gonna have a ton of legal problems I
mean financial problems oh I don't
know if you've been paying attention to
what kiss James is going to do she's
going to cut the Trump organization down
like a fresh cut tree
okay what other questions do we have
here this is fun we should do this more
often
where I just you guys just ask me
questions and I just go on a
tirade
[Music]
let's see
anybody else have a question here I know
there's there's a ton of comments so
it's hard for me to see all of them
because you guys gotta understand like
my comment feed I see YouTube twitch two
Facebook pages so I'm looking at I'm
looking at you know you might be in the
YouTube chat and see a lot of them I'm
seeing triple that
so I gotta I gotta thumb through him I
gotta thumb through him
um Jan asked why did Clarence and his
lovely wife
skip the State of the Union I mean and
then obvious
well I think it's obvious Jan I don't
even I don't know if I I mean because
they're they're q and honors and
they think Joe Biden is somehow part of
the cabal maybe I don't know
let's see here
uh oh will Fox News uh survive if they
lose against Dominion yeah Fox News Will
Survive
they 100 Will Survive
um that Fox News ain't going anywhere I
don't know if you know how Rich
Rupert Murdoch is but uh he's
Rich
um actually here's here's a Tweet
someone sent it here
um thank you uh Margie Margie sent the
tweet from Kyle Chaney it says uh proud
boys defendants say they will subpoena
Donald Trump for trial
oh so it's the pricey
it's the defendants wanting to um to
subpoena him the ones that are on the
chopping block who'd have guessed who'da
guessed
let's see what else do we have
what is the what is the gopn game AKA
goals it's weird Don I mean they have no
they have no their end game is their end
game is to protect their own ass and to
protect their own power at all cost they
don't give a they'll lie they'll
cheat they'll steal they'll elect Liars
they'll support Liars like Santos and
Rhonda Santos and Trump they'll support
Grabbers like Trump they don't
give a Mitch McConnell Kevin
McCarthy all the way down to your local
city councilman that are Republicans
they are there for their power and their
power alone that's it they have no
platform what what platform do they have
they don't like that men dressing
women's clothing and dance
that's their platform drag queens really
wokeness oh you're scared you're scared
of the truth get the out of here
they don't have a goal other than their
power that's their that's always their
end goal that's the reason why democracy
is their enemy and that's the reason why
they'll they'll they'll lose Will trump
flee the country I mean I guess that's a
good question I don't know if he will or
not and I don't know
I don't want him to
yeah I mean if if I had to flip a coin
and say Trump's leaving or Trump's
staying I want him to stay
I mean I think the country wants to see
him you know pay for the crimes
he committed on our on our
democracy and I think the people in New
York want to see him
um pay for the crimes he committed in
New York
um Margie says uh from Bean toast does
Trump and Putin tie together with
Epstein I mean Trump definitely does
if you if you and I don't know if
Putin's in that Circle but I mean if you
look if you look at the Justine Maxwell
trial there was a witness talking about
how Epstein got her in the car
and personally took her over to Donald
Trump's Mar-A-Lago
why else would she go to Mar-A-Lago then
to see the Cheeto dusk you in on her
[Music]
um
wins a-hole Bannon going to jail I mean
um as far as Bannon is concerned he's
still on appeal
which is just a stall tactic I don't
know if he'll win that appeal or not for
that contempt charge I think Mark
Meadows hopes he will
and Peter Navarro hopes he'll win that
appeal
but I don't think he's got much to win
um
um I think he has I don't think he has
much
argument to win that appeal hey Texas
Paul is here Surf's Up he
says everybody say hi to Texas Paul on
the chat we're in the chat today Texas
Pawn
just giving them
just just giving some lessons on on
questions here I figured I'd interact
since uh Gabe can't join us
everyone's telling Texas Paul hello and
good morning Texas ball
here's another question on the same line
will the Trump family I believe some of
the family will flee yes absolutely
uh Kushner and Ivanka yeah they
definitely will flee
um if if now I believe also that they're
trying to protect their own ass
in their own interest
um in other words they're flipping on
him
and you also have to understand
um for genuses Tony don't sugarcoat
no why would I what advantage is it to
me to sugarcoat if you really think
about that for a second I'd like to talk
about this isn't a question but this
this is this is a problem
that is that happens okay this is a
problem that happens this is why I'm
going to show you um here in just a
minute when we get to the top of the
hour I'll take another break after we do
the questions here
um this is a problem that the left-wing
liberal media has right the mainstream
media
they always want to appear to be fair
the problem is
is that they want to tell the truth too
like it's as close as they can get to
the truth
right that that's their goal
and the problem is that the truth really
does hold up
liberal democracy right I mean in this
country right now we have people who
believe in democracy people who don't
and they're willing to lie to any extent
to destroy it
shamelessly lie
to tear down our democracy
so the media has a tough time like oh we
don't want to appear biased you're
biased to the truth who gives a
get over it over it so we have this
we have this challenge in this country
right now
where people don't trust the media
the people Maga definitely I mean
they've been brainwashed into thinking
that everything the media says is fake
that way in case something comes across
a line that they don't like they just
say oh that's fake news they're just
making that up I mean that's that's
the that's the line right
but a lot of liberals don't even trust
the news because of the headlines they
come out with I mean Jesus Christ retail
sales went up by three percent in
January like what and and it just
after unemployment drops to the lowest
point in the 50-year history
and the headlines were why why is why is
the largest unemployment or the why is
the the largest employment in history
and and the and retail sales growing by
three percent bad for Biden and
Democrats like what the what in the
are you talking about
it's good for the country dummies it's
good for the country
and if you don't see that good for the
country could be possibly good for
either party
in a normal timeline you're not seeing
why your headlines are so skewed
you're trying to not be biased in the
act of being biased it's really
dumb
um so that's a problem that we have so
that's why don't sugarcoat things that's
why that's why I started this show in
the first place
I actually believe we got a tiny
audience you guys are the best audience
in the world but a tiny audience
compared to some others I mean uh people
like Steve Bannon and Ben Shapiro and
Matt Walsh and the daily wire uh even
the Midas touch Brothers there's
hundreds of thousands of people that
watch them every single day
right now here's what I believe here's
what I believe
I believe my show this show me
this is going to be the biggest
political commentary show in the entire
country that's what I believe and the
reason why I believe it is because what
I say and how I say it
it is tough for people not to pay
attention once they come here and start
to listen
now I mean I have to get in front of
more and more people right I mean and
that's the challenge with media right to
say hey I gotta try to try to promote
myself and promote the show and people
have to find it to know that I'm saying
these things
but eventually it's going to catch on
I I mentioned
um I think it was about a week or so ago
that people referred to me as the uh
Limbaugh of the left and it does not
offend me matter of fact I want to lean
into it
I am not scared to be called the
rushland ball the left
rushland ball used his talents great
talents for very vile evil
he his talent is one of the reasons why
our country's in the shape it's in
because he used it for such scummy
things to destroy our democracy
not to hold it up
and if I can use what talent I have to
talk into the microphone and give you
the commentary and look through the
Periscope of democracy and the
institution of democracy to advance it
and to save it just for the sake of
Liberty and Liberty alone
then I am willing to do that and I am
not offended when someone calls me the
rushland ball of the left I do not give
a matter of fact I want more people
to say it
hell if you're my fan call me that if
you're here if you're a listener call me
that rather you love me or you love to
hate me call me the rushland ball the
left
think about this for a second in
messaging and narrative right I'll give
you I'll give you the behind the scenes
look
of the show in messaging a narrative and
this is what I believe from the very
beginning if I would create a show that
sounded looked and felt like right wing
talk radio I could get a lot of people
to pay attention because it's not about
what you say first it's about how you
say it that's the first that's the very
first tenement of entertainment you must
have stage presence you must be
entertaining
how you say something is really
important why do you think
I knocked David Pac-Man all the time hey
David you're boring as
you're boring dude you're boring
and if you're hearing me and you're
watching this and you and you're
you're mad at me because I'm calling you
boring it's because you are
I'm not saying David Patman couldn't not
be boring he could be a hell of a lot
less boring I mean just you know talk a
little faster
pull pull your head out of your ass and
say a curse word every once in a while
it's not going to kill you okay it's not
gonna kill you it might catch your
audience's attention and that's the
point is to catch attention once you
catch attention in media then you get
this then you get the messaging
then they hear it the ears here Don
comes here every day and hears me
yelling and screaming and he hates every
minute of it good for him stay here Don
go tell all your stupid
Republican buddies that I am the
rushland ball the left because that's
what I want that's what I want more than
anything else that's what I want
is I want those people out there that
have been mind by the right to
think that somehow liberalism is the
is is the foundation of weakness
and somehow
these boneheads lost their way
and I will show them away the way back
to strength
I will show you how to use your
your machismo to defend the lgbtq
community to defend the liberty of
people of color
to defend the bodily autonomy of women
I'll show you how to use that
masculinity
that white privilege I'll show you how
to do it
I'll show you how to use your white
privilege to tear white privilege to the
ground burn it and piss on the
ashes that's what I'm here to do
I believe in this country if we get rid
of the idea of white privilege
and we give everyone Equity inequality
everyone the chance
every single person
the chance
at Liberty just a shred of Liberty
that we will be much better off as a
country now and in the future and
democracy delivers us that folks that's
the delivery system our freedom our
rights that Constitution is it perfect
no it's never going to be perfect
is it difficult you goddamn right it's
hard why do you think liberalism is
strong not weak because it's a
it's a to get
330 million people to agree on something
and to form a society that is based on
freedom rights and Liberty and minding
your own business
mind your own business
they say they want they say they want
small government unless it has to do
with the uterus they say they want small
government and let's have to do with
your genitalia they say they want small
government let's have to do with your
pronouns they're the ones obsessed with
this stuff not us they're
obsessed with it
Jesus Christ you write your pronoun in
your goddamn bio and you'll get 1500
mogadites to lose their
minds because you typed it out in your
bio who's the snowflake who's the
ass in that situation is it the
person who typed out a few words or is
it the person who's getting offended by
those words
you're you're the snowflakes
you're the ass Maga
you're the ones whining and crying about
how you're losing your white privilege
and your country's going away
because people are getting equality and
Equity get the out of here with
that nonsense
I'm here to tell you 100 from my
experience in life with white male
privilege
from White America that it's just not
true it's not true they are
lying to you dummy they're lying to you
cracker they're lying to you
so yeah that's the message that I want
to send to every single person who
thinks they love Rosalind ball who
thinks Rush Limbaugh was the greatest
thing since sliced bread wait till they
find out
wait
until they find out
about the rushland ball of the left
stick around we'll be right back with
shitless Roundup and this this chat
thing was fun we'll be right back right
after this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the words that I'm struggling with I
chose Babble Mega Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
foreign podcast
welcome back to the show Boy we have
some I have some more energy and I have
some keto dust q and honor statements
the range statements to go through we
got some work to do here in the second
hour folks that's right two full hours
every single day
[Music]
simulgancing from the minus touch
Facebook page for speaking of that while
you're on Facebook go over and follow my
page at the Tony Michaels and also
follow the Twitter page at Tony Michaels
pod on Twitter you're not going to want
to miss the bonehead of the week poll
we're probably gonna put it out early
we're not really sure and we have a
scheduling conflict tomorrow but we're
gonna make it happen you know every
single Friday in the second hour we go
through bonehead of the week where you
vote you decide so don't forget to
subscribe to the YouTube channel if
you're here as well you can vote on the
community tab every single Thursday for
bonehead of the week
bonehead of the weak bonehead of the
week and I want to thank all the members
of the patreon over there
at the fam over on patreon I
really appreciate it you guys are swell
I I had no idea that we would get this
quickly uh to the number that I think
we're at 82 right now today I believe
that's the number hang on a second let
me check it now I met my
my command yeah 82. our first goal is
100 so we're so close
to 100 members and several people over
there sent me private messages
um I appreciate that I'm gonna try to
get back to you and if you do if you
join and you want to send me a private
message over there you can it doesn't
matter what tier you're on you can send
me a private message over there and I'll
respond I try to get to all the the DMS
over there and if I haven't responded to
you I will I will I'll get to the the
message over there so if you if you go
on patreon.com the Tony Michaels you can
join for just five dollars or you can
select the other tiers take a look at
what's in there there's some merch
discounts you'll get some exclusive
access to the
um the the other content that I create
not the show here the show is always
free show is always free this two-hour
show is always free we're gonna try to
get the three
and that's why I want to reach that goal
of 100 over on patreon so any support is
important though I don't care if it's
paid support this is my job now this has
become my job and because it's my job I
have to make a living
but how I make a living is your support
and it doesn't necessarily mean
Financial
if you can afford five dollars ten
dollars sure but if you can't you can't
afford to spread the message you can
afford to share it you can afford to
like comment come here every single day
and listen
send it the link to your family your
friends like-minded people make sure
make sure to let them know
at the left wing wrestling ball is on a
tirade
serious I'm serious I'm telling you once
people find out that that that thing
that it scares the out it scares
the out of the left it really does
it scares the out of liberals my my
style
it's frightening to them it's not to you
not to you but who I'm talking about is
the the the left-wing media
establishment the actual liberal media
establishment I'm not talking about CNN
or MSNBC or or the or the New York Times
or whatever the right wing calls the
mainstream Media or the left-wing media
that's not who I'm talking about I'm
talking about actual left-wing media I'm
frighten the out of them
I I terrify them they don't know what to
do with me they don't know how to react
I am not like your average every day MPR
guest I just I'm not I'm not gonna be
it's not who I am that's not my
political commentary and that's not how
I'm going to use my voice as a hammer to
crush these fascists
I just believe that there's a better way
my way is the best so that's how I
am going to do it and I appreciate that
you guys appreciate it
because I get comments every day
every day on YouTube and twitch on the
patreon page on Facebook
that I that I'm real and raw it's in the
title or the the intro
that I don't hold back I have no
to give
because I truly don't but it's because
of you it is you I want you to
understand that that without your ears
this microphone would not be possible
that is the most important support that
you can give
so if you can go over to patreon Great
check it out if you can share this show
with three people great do that please
if you can tell your Uncle Earl hey have
you heard this Rush let Rush Limbaugh
left you're gonna love him
tell your Uncle Earl that I'm serious
you got my you got Maga
you got Maga family
share the link and tell them that people
are saying I'm Lim the limb all the left
oh they'll be here every day
pissed off as Dawn every day
they'll just be pissed
and then maybe one day they'll pluck
their head out of their ass and realize
what I'm saying is the truth maybe just
maybe I mean you know we'll convert
several of them Chris n has been here
the whole time is Chris in here today
Chris are you here Chris has been here
the whole time when I I swear to
you Chris was here when I had like I
don't know 10 people watching what was
it MJ eight nine ten people MJ's been
here since the beginning too
I don't know if MJ's in the Chant today
but Chris and Chris in has been here the
whole damn time they stayed they stay
around folks they can't stop listening
to this and the reason why is
because I'm interesting I ain't
like NPR David backman boring as
same old nope
and I don't have any to give so I
you know and I'm pretty good with curse
words I do have to admit sometimes when
I go back and look at Clips I'm like God
damn I know how to cuss
son of a I know how to
sling some curse words like a
but you know that's just
it's just uh how I've always been so I
appreciate the the chat uh segment that
we did I think I think I'm gonna try to
do that more often did you guys have fun
doing that that was fun maybe
we'll do a q a type thing uh once a week
or something
once a week we'll do something like that
uh let's see is Chris here I want to
bring Chris up if he's here
someone tell me Chris is here where
where is he
I mean he's usually here he's been here
since the beginning
and it's usually just a top hat that he
puts in that's how I know
that's right I know the OG's the OG
fam I Know Who You Are I
remember I'm serious
um it was two years ago
two years ago when we first started the
show I mean we were like um three or
four episodes in at this point two years
ago in 2021
and I had like eight nine ten people
listening uh yeah that's MJ says like
10. it's like 10 people
listen Amanda says originally there was
like 50 listeners and Amanda's OG too
absolutely
you guys stick around
and the reason why is because I'm not
boring I'm not trying to bore
you to death I'm trying to give
you the facts and give you what you need
to know and how you need to know it and
and try to give you an idea what the
government how it works how
Civics works
I dropped out of college twice okay I
I'm not afraid to say it I'm a two-time
College Dropout I graduated high school
pretty easy though don't don't get too
rough on me
but I I majored in history and political
science I've been interested in politics
since I was 14 years old
I was watching Bill Maher Politically
Incorrect
and Ted copples Nightline
I'm not that I'm not you I
would watch I would watch Ted Cobble
Nightline and Then followed up by Bill
Maher's Politically Incorrect now Bill
Maher is a little off now
but back then it was different it was
different
it was way different
um art song As Art SCI here excuse me
says on YouTube Pac-Man is too soft I
mean I don't know if the word is soft I
mean that might be the word you use but
he's boring he's boring
use David use a curse word every
once in a while for Christ's sake Jesus
you can bleep it you pre-record
your you don't go live I mean he
does live streams you can cuss on a live
stream Man YouTube don't give a I
mean they do if you cuss too much like
me but yeah one f word is not gonna
destroy your YouTube channel David ah
damn that's all I'm saying that's all
I'm saying
Mighty Librarians is it's shocking how
many college students have no knowledge
of civics
you know I think that's a big problem
Mighty librarian I think that's a huge
problem in our country I actually
believe that we should teach kids less
math from the time that they're like
three till about 18 we should teach them
less math and a hell lot more civics
less science hell of a lot more Civics I
know it sounds crazy but do you use
calculus every day in your job
do you
do you and even if you need to know how
to do math you can't Google that
you can't
come on but as a society as a democracy
we should fundamentally understand
exactly how not only our democracy works
but how all forms of government works
and how the current forms of government
around the world works I'm saying we
should know our national civics
we should know we should know state
governments
County governments City councils
school boards and we should know all of
them how they all work everyone's a
little bit different every state is
every did you know this that every state
has its own Constitution did you know
don't even know that
they're like oh the Constitution we the
Constitution and they don't even know
that their state has a
constitution
they have no clue they don't even know
that the town they live in has a charter
no clue don't know it didn't
know it won't know it
and it's because they're not
educated this is easy stuff to know too
by the way that's like all this
about public schools we went over this
yesterday with Nikki Haley this
this loser talking about how she
she didn't want to do the same thing
Trump does where we need to put parents
back in control of schools parents have
control of schools dummies you got you
got an election to vote for school board
members you boneheads you elect
governors
who appoint state boards of Education
you boneheads what the
don't you get about government and
democracy what the don't you
understand you have these choices these
are choices that you are making and then
you're bitching about the choices that's
why I said yesterday that's why I said
yesterday people might have got all
pissed off I don't know I really didn't
see any comments maybe no one was pissed
off maybe everyone thought is telling
the truth
but this train derailment
in this town where they had the meeting
and I guess they I guess they
had some kind of town hall and they
didn't get the answers they were looking
for but it's the people of Ohio who are
to blame for that derailment and
that that chemical accident it's them
they're to blame
oh Tony God damn that's harsh you damn
right it is it's the harsh truth what do
you want me to what do you want me to do
about the truth what the you want
me to do
hiding underneath the pillow or do you
want me to hit you with it and
then you realize oh yeah that
makes sense
the reason why the reason why it is the
people's fault of Ohio for a lot of
their problems is because they're voting
in boxes
they voted for Trump twice folks
they voted for JD Vance they voted for
dewine there's no election stolen there
any kind of Nefarious going on
there those people are voting for
scumbags they're voting for Liars who
don't give a about the people in
that town they're voting for
them
it's the it's our people who do not
fundamentally understand what the
they're voting for and who they're
voting for and it is my job my job to
tell you
what the is going on
in a way that you will pay
attention and they will pay
attention
yeah do I have to yell and scream and
make a big scene yeah sure yep you do
George Carlin had a bit one time because
uh the phrase It's The Quiet Ones You
Gotta watch right it's The Quiet Ones
You Gotta watch that's all he
does a bit George Carlin does a bit
where if you walked into a bar and there
was a guy sitting in the corner in a
dark corner reading a book minding his
own business not saying a
goddamn thing
right got his head down not bothering
anybody and then there's a guy standing
on top of the bar with the machete
beating on the bar I'm gonna kill the
next that moves
who are you gonna watch
Who you gonna watch
so just take it I'm standing on top of
the bar with a machete
pound on the machete they're gonna steal
your democracy that's that's what that's
what I'm trying to do
that's it that's it Dave Pacman's guy in
the corner I don't want to standing on
the bar that's why I know we're going to
be the biggest political show in the
country
because I don't hide behind comedy
either right like like I don't I don't
you I mean yeah is it funny is
it entertaining course do we try to make
you laugh sure
again it's not about what you say first
it's about how you say it
that's that's that's why
but I don't hide behind comedy right I
don't say I'm a comedian there's nowhere
in my bio that says I'm a comedian
I mean do we like to have fun do we like
to joke around we we use Gabe Sanchez
our co-host is our is our comic relief
he's a comedian I'm not
this is pure unadulterated commentary
folks
I do not give a it is commentary
I ain't commentating
on the state of our country and our
Civic and social issues and political
issues right now so let's get to it
let's go to shitless Roundup where we
round up all the Tweety tweets and
training trends of the day start the
countdown
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
treats and trendy trends of the day we
gotta go through the list here you
see this box he's on my list
oh my God look at this gay oh he looks
so sad and so confused Mike Pence
where's the fly I was looking for the
fly earlier you think he keeps that
in his pocket I don't know
maybe uh here's Mike Pence's um you want
to call it his explanation of why he's
gonna defy The subpoena let's let's
listen back on January 6 president Trump
was wrong
uh oh no Sherlock oh did you hear
that well it's February 16th 2023
and Mike Pence gets in front of a
microphone as he's being subpoenaed by a
criminal grand jury in Washington by his
special counsel Jack Smith
that Donald Trump
oh boy was he wrong let's continue as
I've said before his words were Reckless
and they endangered my family and
everyone at the Capitol so why the
are you defending him you coward huh
what the makes you want to defend
this gutless turd
if you you are such you you ass
God damn that's such a good
phrase for you I told you
yesterday that I told Gabe Sanchez that
I was going to replace snowflakes with
ass every single time new
replacement ass and yeah I
could say PAB to censor it make it all
nice and fuzzy I mean we're gonna put
PAB on some of the merch and we're gonna
put ass on some of the merch
I promise this merch is coming we're
working on it
but I'm just gonna say it ass
let's go
I had no right to overturn the election
no then why were
here's the thing
if Mike Pence really does think that he
did not have the ability to overturn the
election why was he looking for a reason
right during the January 6th select
hearings the one thing that pissed me
off about the January 6 uh committee
more than anything is they made this
guy into a hero
they made him into a hero as if he saved
the country
he was pressured into saving the country
he was forced into saving the country to
save his own ass because his attorneys
was telling him look it's crime it's
criminal to do what those
are telling you to do
there's no legal Avenue
to do what they're saying you should do
it's the illegal
it's against the law
you will go to prison
that's why that's why he seemed so
heroic are you telling me that the bar
for the vice president of the United
States
when he's overseeing the joint sessions
to certify our votes the bar is
don't break the law for hero get the
out of here with that nonsense now
I'll give Mike Pence credit after Donald
Trump
sicked his violent mob on him
they wanted to hang him he changed his
mind a bit and decided to defend
democracy instead of being complacent to
the Cheeto dust q and honor and he did a
part of his job that he was
supposed to be not just reaching the bar
of minimal effort to not overturn an
election illegally get the out of
here
um but I would say in this very moment
it's also wrong
to establish a precedent
where
a legislative official could be called
into a court by an executive branch you
are not a legislative official
you're not you're the vice
president of the United States
this is the stupidest thing I've
ever heard of this speech and debate
clause and the reason why it's really
stupid is because it's not like
it's been a hundred years since this has
been challenged it's been months Lindsey
Graham challenged this same stupid
thing for the same stupid
reason and lost lost he's gonna
lose Mike Pence is gonna lose
this effort
into trying to convince Congress or to
try and convince the courts that he can
hide crime
behind the speech and debate clause
that's not a thing that's not a
thing it's not
we know that from the decisions in the
Lindsey Graham Georgia case let's listen
answer that that runs against literally
hundreds of years of not only American
law but no common law now we're going to
stand for that principle because what
the does that mean common law well
what does that mean what what the
does that mean
he's just making up now
and you know he's just making up
and the reason why is because his
attorneys has told him this phrase
and he's he's trying to memorize it and
he's trying to get every point in that
the attorneys told him to say in this
moment because they knew they were going
to get this question so he was you know
he's trying to you know position himself
where he doesn't say anything he
didn't want to say out in the open into
a microphone that's why he looks
dumb
that's why he looks stupid is because
this is a stupid argument but this is
their argument I mean a lot of
their arguments are dumb because it's a
separation of powers and nope and that's
right
into the court go go go fight and go
lose you dumb
go lose and you should be excited out
there that Mike Pence is gonna he's
challenging this folks the only reason
why I'm talking about this this morning
and we get to spend this narrative and
we get to talk more about it and you can
talk about it too whoever you can talk
about it to is because Mike Pence is
challenging this
we are able to mock these
because they are acting so goddamn
complacent and stupid
this is not going to end well for them
I mean as long as we stay engaged it
will not end well for them and if needs
to be taken to the Supreme Court of the
United States
President Trump okay take it to the
Supreme Court of the United States they
really think them Trump judges are going
to save them don't they here's a problem
here's the problem is that they didn't
save Lindsey Graham no all right they
didn't save Lindsey Graham
they're not going to save Mike Pence
either
um here is a Mueller sharout Allison has
um Allison Gill of mutual Roots has this
statement here uh from Trump and I'm
going to read the statement but she says
here's what she says about the statement
LOL the statement makes me Ponder
if judge Burl Howe has granted Jack
Smith motion to compel
Koran I think this is it and to testify
under the crime fraud exception remember
we've been talking about this uh where
Donald Trump's attorney uh
is being compelled to testify because
they were hiding crime there's no
attorney-client privilege if if you're
criming uh we know that for sure with
the John Eastman email case it's pretty
simple but Donald Trump this is what
made Allison uh surmise this the Cheeto
desk q-9er says radical left hating
Trump Jesus Christ this guy
who this is why I don't tweet the way I
talk can you imagine if I tweeted my
show what it would sound like it
would be ridiculous
absolutely ridiculous my voice and the
way I talk and how I talk in the I
say is not designed to be read
are written
it's designed to be listened to it's
like music right
I have a certain Cadence I know it I try
it
um he says the radical left Trump hating
special
prosecutor Quotes no he's like you know
like he is he is the special counsel
like that's it's not he anyways Jack
Smith is leaking to the fake news media
like a sib
is leaking to the media okay here's
here's the here's the bang-up job that
he's doing is the only reason why we
know what we know about the documents
case and the only reason why I I can
surmise that he stole the documents to
cover up his Cheeto desk kangaroo 2 is
because he leaked to the media it's
dumb he says uh the the the the
vat slob goes on to say he is going
absolutely crazy trying to NAB the
political candidate who is way ahead of
his boss quote in the polls he means
Biden
and won the 2020 presidential election
except for the fact that it was rigged
rigged okay
I'm I I keep saying this and I don't
know why some folks don't believe me yet
this statement right here he's telling
you his plan folks he is going
absolutely crazy to NAB the political
candidate
he means a republican nominee who is is
way ahead of his boss in the polls which
is not true but you know
whatever polls suck anyways he's telling
you he's telling you what he's gonna do
right here
okay goes on to say yeah he continues if
you're listening uh to this on the audio
version yeah he's he typed out a lot of
here a lot of his his post
on true social I've gotten longer and
longer and longer
remember when he used to just post make
America great again and it was like yeah
his his cult was excited now he
can't do that anymore he's got to try to
back talk and explain to them
why he's not guilty now he goes on to
say he's got a job to do and is working
hard to scare and intimidate Witnesses
oh my God this is pure unadulterated
projection here folks Donald Trump for
sure
is trying to intimidate Witnesses in
this case
100 percent
100 percent I almost bet that's maybe
the reason why Mike Pence is willing to
go to the mat all the way to the Supreme
Court for this subpoena he's scaring and
intimidate Witnesses I'm just saying
he's always projecting this game now
even lawyers who have never seen such
Antics before there's lawyers out there
that are so stupid they don't know how
special prosecutor Powers work oh my God
who would have thought dumb people can
get their law license too
um he goes on to puke up he should be
looking at the election fraud and who's
spied on my campaign I'm literally
that's the end of it who spied on my
campaign he keeps talking about this
spying on his campaign
you know why he keeps doing that right
do you know why he keeps talking about
the spying on his campaign
is because they were colluding with
Russians they were spying on Russians
right okay let me let me tell you how it
works
they were spying on Russians trying to
interfere in our election in 2016 and
they intercepted the Trump campaign
colluding with those Russians
so they were spying on the Russians and
the Trump campaign was colluding with
those Russians so that's what he means
by spied on my campaign okay that's the
projection there and all you trumpers
out there that's what he's trying to
tell you I don't know I don't know if
you know that or not I don't know if you
you realize that but that is what the
he's doing
now Province Supply says there was a
very good reason for them to spy on
Trump again
they were spying on Trump's campaign
because they caught the intercepts of
them colluding with Russians they were
spying on this is difficult to
understand this stuff I mean it's not
hard
and isn't and so there there's there's a
little taste of how um grandpa poopy
pants is losing his mind
about Jack Smith but I I want to do you
one better here I want to do one better
um he's he's freaking out about Tish
James too and then I want to show you um
I want to show you because uh we're at
the bottom of the second hour
I want to show you this uh Chelsea
Handler thing and I also want to show
you this the Buffalo Mass shooter his
statements uh in his trial his apology
um it's very telling uh and it's why we
need to fight for our democracy and
fight against these fascists and
these real America First Nazis it's the
reason why because they're out to
Stoke stochastic terrorism and
it is very clear in the statements of
this Buffalo Mass shooter here is um
here's another statement by him where
he's trying to stoke stochastic
terrorism by the way this is what he's
doing
in this in this post here
he's trying to get people to try to
hurt tis James
so what he's doing and I even say I say
dude is awake and obsessing over
stopping tis James with 2A Bros okay
here's how he's doing it let me show you
this statement this is from this morning
he was tweeting this this morning of
course Tish James is really the problem
that Trump has with tis James is not tis
James isn't going to put him in jail
tits James is going to destroy the Trump
organization
the actual money laundering machine that
he has had for decades she's going to
she's going to smash that up into
smithereens
and that that's really going to hurt him
and his family he's going to be not only
is he going to be like he's broke now
but he's going to be really
broke
um regime asks why isn't this against
the law are you talking about this
statement here I mean because he's he's
not being he's not being obvious about
he's not saying go kill her I mean he's
not saying that that's why it's
stochastic terrorism
it's not it's not actual Terry he's not
he's not calling for his supporters it's
it's a dog whistle right he does this so
This is actually one of the things he
does really well believe it or not he
understands the language of the demented
because he is demented okay so here's
this statement about Tish James now I'll
listen to the very first part very
carefully
everyone has to step up and support the
National Rifle Association NRA
against the quote racist in Reverse oh
my God New York State Attorney General
Leticia James okay
this is more of the stand back and
standby right you remember the
debate with him and Joe Biden and and
and Joe Biden invokes the proud boys and
Donald Trump says the proud boys stand
back and stand by right and then the
proud boys came January 6 and tried to
overturn our constitution
and they're on trial now for seditious
conspiracy
seems these two things seem to have
something to do with each other
but he is telling 2A gun nuts the same
that were out in their
yard shooting at the Chinese spy balloon
those same thought that
their rifles could reach 60 000 feet in
the air and take down a balloon
that had an apparatus the size of three
school buses attached to it the out
of here you boneheads but that's who
he's talking to here he's talking to the
balloonatics
here when he's saying this
he said everyone has to step up and
support the National Rifle Association
against the racist in Reverse he's
saying go kill the black woman hey hey
you white racist that are in the NRA you
gotta step up and help me out because he
goes on to say who is fighting with
every ounce of her strength
meaning her being her physical being
which shouldn't be much to destroy the
NRA
and the Republican Party along with it
oh they're going to destroy the GOP no
she's not she she's not destroying the
GOP she's just destroying the capability
of the GOP to use the NRA to funnel
Russian money into our politics I don't
know if you know that or not I don't
know if you're aware of that or not but
the NRA is is becoming apparatus for
Russia
to inject its money into our
political politics in our country
foreign money uh her office quote she
has an actual office dummy it's not I
mean anyways he put quotes around office
dumb he says her office is
consumed with the NRA
and then in parentheses and me
wink wink wink loyalty with massive
amounts of time money effort devoted to
this as opposed to stopping record
violent
and other crime in New York state he's
telling you hey be violent go do this I
if you don't think this is stochastic
terrorism you're you're a dumb
you're a stupid if you
don't think what he's doing here The
Stoke stand back and stand by proud boys
go go steal the Constitution so I can be
your king
out of here exactly what he's
saying in that statement
he's losing his mind he's really he's
really pissed off he's really pissed off
that Jack Smith is going to him up
and he's pissed off that uh a woman tis
James is going to cut down his
organization speaking of weak fragile
men
being absolutely upset about a strong
woman oh my God have you watched this
Chelsea Handler Matt Walsh Tucker
Carlson
Chelsea Handler put out a video talking
about how she's glad she didn't have
kids look and it's a comedy video it's
funny it's well yeah she's a comedian
remember I was talking just a minute ago
about how I don't hide behind comedy I'm
not a comedian I'm a commentator I do
political and social commentary that's
what the I do
I mean yeah it doesn't make you laugh
sometimes sure I tried I try to make you
laugh trying to make it entertaining but
Chelsea Handler is an Entertainer she is
a comedian
and she was doing jokes about in this
video about her not having kids and it's
funny haha it's funny like objectively
funny because she's a good comedian
unlike right-wing who
aren't funny but holy did a bunch
of white ass cracker men take High
offense that she doesn't want to have a
baby oh my God you you
don't want to have a big that's why
you're put on this plant I mean they
couldn't show it anymore than how they
think of women as brood mares
like how in the what the is wrong
with you people you you not only want to
strip a woman's right away for her
health care choices you want to force
her to have a baby so much so that you
you people give off really rapey Vibes
Tucker and Matt Walsh and Ben Shapiro
it's really rapey of you
to go after a woman because she doesn't
want to have a kid you are a dumb when
did you oh that's right
you've always been fascist
um here's Chelsea's
um uh tweet here to her response I can't
show the original video of hers because
it's a Daily Show video so they'll
knock me here on YouTube but I
can show this clip because this is her
social media video
um in response to these chuckleheads and
it's oh it's it's beautiful it's
a beautiful watch a day in the life of a
childless woman the point is to make you
feel good about being an aging deeply
unlikable woman who never had kids
feminists like Chelsea Handler they've
been lied to by their society forever
that you could be a girl boss and you
can do anything a man can do which
everyone who's ever seen a woman back up
a vehicle knows that's not true oh my
God oh my God
these these poor said acts of what
a ass that he has to
use a line like if you've ever seen a
woman back up a car I mean there's
plenty of dudes that can't parallel park
dummy have you ever have you ever
watched some dude who doesn't know how
to parallel park parallel park he
doesn't he doesn't he doesn't look like
a woman but he can't parallel this is
really stupid stuff
can you believe that your
parents listen to this garbage and
they're like yeah your mom's like yeah
those women none of them can
back up cars not even me what the
am I this is hilarious this is
hilarious and the best part about this
is
she didn't say anything to them
she just did a video that's it she just
did a video
oh my God that that is crazy ass
that she puts out a video on this I
don't know who this who this bearded
wish.com Donald Trump Jr is but
his response to her video like she she's
like she's making jokes about not being
a woman who doesn't want to have a baby
she doesn't want to have kids right like
oh well of course she doesn't she
doesn't know how to back up a car
you weak let's keep
listening because Chelsea's rings in
here I promise you Chelsea gets in on
the end and it's it's beautiful womb
resembles a dried up Tumbleweed blowing
down an old western town and your
Valentine's Day date for the 10th year
in a row is a 10 year old copy of Magic
Mike and a half full bottle of Xanax
this lady is miserable I mean she is
miserable and it's ridden all over her
face how miserable she is
oh my God here she comes now before I
play this I I gotta I gotta I gotta
comment on on Ben Shapiro there
um
oh my God
Ben dude she she wasn't talking to you
she wasn't talking to you because really
frankly Ben Shapiro couldn't get a woman
pregnant if he tried he couldn't how
could he how could he you think you
think there's a woman that okay well
let's just let Chelsea does a much
better job than me let's let's watch
hey everyone I woke up this morning well
more like this afternoon and noticed
that there was an emergency meeting of
the receding hairline Society to discuss
a comedy video I filmed about not
wanting kids
wow why would I even need my own
children when I get to hear these cry
babies all the time I mean I can't
believe that bearded version of Tucker
Carlson thinks I would take a half a
bottle of Xanax I'd take way more than
that you silly goose look okay so let me
she goes on here and I'm gonna play it I
promise I promise but I just want to say
there there is a reason why you do not
with a real comedian right you you
just you don't really want to get in a
word fight
with a really good comedian it's not a
thing you want to do Ted Cruz
has done this with Seth Rogen before
where he got into a word fight with Seth
Rogan it's like dude is it really a
thing you want to do like comedians are
masters of words like that's that's
their craft that's the whole point
that's what they do you're just a
professional box how do you think
you match up against a professional
comedian who is one of the best
comedians in the world and if you don't
think that Chelsea Handler is one of the
best comedian in the world just watch
how she puts it to the screws to these
douchebags I don't want to debate
whether or not I'm a girl boss although
I did just look at my bank account and
think that's pretty cool boss and then I
thought about the 10 different people
plus 10 plus different people I've been
able to put through college and then I
remember my six New York Times
best-selling books or was it five oh no
no it was six and then I remember my
recent stand-up special that was just
released on Netflix called Revolution
and I thought yeah you are a girl boss
you guys seemed so triggered by me I
mean my goodness Tucker I think it is
time for you to ask yourself a serious
question are you really upset about how
much freedom I have or are you upset
that you haven't been able to take it
away from me yet oh and quick shout out
to Ben Shapiro thank you for helping my
cause of not having children who needs
the birth control pill when your voice
is 100 effective I don't need a husband
Ben because I'm in a relationship with
myself and at least in my relationship
someone can get a woman to come and by
all means Tucker if you want to respond
to my triggers I will be happy to keep
putting out videos as long as you want I
think we both know that you are a hate
masturbating to me and I'm down with
that
oh my God
oh my God if you if you did not love
Chelsea Handler before this
I and you don't and you don't love her I
don't know what the wrong with
you holy and again this goes back
to what I just said don't it's not a
really good idea to get into a word
fight
with a person who's really really good I
mean they pay her
they pay her
to drag people
to burn people to the ground with her
words and you're gonna get into a word
fight with her this is the person that
you have chosen to get into a word fight
with you are a I mean I really did think
that Matt Walsh was going on
hey that played again uh let me find the
tweet from Matt Walsh because Matt Walsh
did this and he was going after her a
couple times here here's here's this one
and and I I quote tweeted him uh Matt
Walsh him
he said he said one thing to keep in
mind about Chelsea Handler is that she
has actually had three children but she
murdered all of them he's talking about
abortions he's saying that Women's
Health Care is murder here and the only
reason why he's saying that is because
he couldn't even if he was a
woman because he doesn't know what a
woman is but even if he was one he
couldn't carry a a baby to turn
that ass
and he's talking about abortions that
she might have had health care and then
he goes on to say that's why she's so
desperately justifies her childlessness
her Freedom was purchased with the blood
of her own children
[Music]
really pissed off that Chelsea Handler
was successful because she had abortions
that's what he's saying she had
abortions and that's what made her
successful that's what made her be able
to keep doing comedy and keep doing the
things that she wanted to do behind the
freedom and liberty to live her life the
way that she wanted to live
okay here's what I said you still
talking about Chelsea I mean dude these
guys wouldn't stop man wouldn't stop I
mean it triggered them hard it
triggered him triggered them hard what a
bunch of ass
that's my new word for snowflake
them
okay and there's one other clip I want
to show you here
and let's see if I can find it oh here
it is uh someone had it we're 45 minutes
into the second hour
I'm sure this will take me about 15
minutes
uh maybe 10 and then we'll do some
announcements at the end I promise and
I'm going to consider
naming and doing the Q a section
um on the uh on the show I had a lot of
fun answering your guys you guys typing
in questions me answering them uh so I'm
I'm I've been thinking about this the
whole time see I can talk and think at
the same time
I think we might try to find a name for
that and do that once a week
um so so do me a favor get into the
comments down below whether you're on
Facebook or YouTube I would prefer if
you go to YouTube or go to patreon and
DM me
um and give me your ID addiction
and and the moderators will take note
too and they're always watching we have
the best moderators in the world they're
always watching the chat for some of
these things
um three hours ahead people are saying
three hours of course I know you want
three hours I I want to do three hours I
promise you I really truly do want to do
three hours but it is my job to do this
and I I have to make a living it is a
thing and I want and I and you guys give
me so much support it's very important
to recognize not just the monetary
support that you may give and because I
don't I don't get paid to do this
there's no one paying a salary to me I I
just I come here every day and talk in
the microphone and you guys listen the
only way for me to continue to do this
to make a living is to somehow make
income one way I'll I'll be right
transparent with you right here one way
that I make income is the merch
um I showed you our newest design here
it is surfset you go to
store.dtonymichaels.com and if you buy a
Surf's Up shirt or any
other merch any other merch whether you
want a Rhonda santis can go himself
coffee mug whatever merch you want out
there I get a portion of that so you buy
it you get the little thing coffee mug
the T-shirt cool design and then I get a
little bit right I just get a little
portion of it that's one way that I make
money that's one way I make money to
keep doing this the other way that I
make money doing this is I actually post
clips of bonehead of the week you guys
know that I clip something and I post it
over on Midas touch's YouTube channel my
YouTube channel is not monetized that's
why you can't do Super Chat the reason
why is because I don't give a and
I'm gonna start I'm gonna keep saying
the I wanna say I don't give a
if YouTube likes it or not I don't give
a I am gonna there is a chance in
one of these days that I will not be
allowed on YouTube because of my
mouth as soon as they find out who I am
and how effective it is they'll probably
not want me there anymore
so I I know my YouTube channel is not
monetized for a lot of different reasons
but that's one of them is because my
mouth they do not want to
monetize my channel because I'm vulgar
oh oh how sh how sad
so I don't I don't get to monetize there
that's why we don't have super chats we
tried that we got cut off I can't get it
back I've tried several times I can't
get it back I don't make money on
YouTube
unless I take a clip and I post it on
Midas Touch the my zealous Brothers have
been partners with us for over a year
and they're great support for us they've
been a great partnership for us
because what happens is I don't get paid
Super PAC money I don't get paid a
salary I don't get paid to do this show
what happens is I cut my clip
and I posted over on minus touch and I
get advertising dollars because they
sell ads on that video so I I split it
with them in essence so might is touched
I mean they they don't pay me but they
we split and revenue that's how it works
that's how it works I make money that
way I make money that way some people
some people give me tips they go to
tonymichaels.com and they give me a tip
and just just like in a PayPal tip
type thing the other way that we've that
we've monetized recently is through the
patreon page
that's that's the other way that we
have monetized and with the patreon it's
a little different because I'm not
really monetizing this show with it
um I'm giving you extra content you get
additional discounts on merch I'm do I'm
giving you early access to social media
videos I do a special rant we're gonna
do we're gonna do ask me anything
sessions we're going to do uh one-on-one
we're gonna do patreon parties
where you can where you can join a
patreon party it's all there on the
patreon and you can go take a look at it
so I appreciate any support you can give
not just monetary support it is so
important that you guys watch as much as
you possibly can for as long as you can
if you don't have time to watch
the show in two hours wait till it's
over you can actually go and you can you
can watch it in a fast
setting so you can like change how fast
I talk
by clicking the little gear on the
YouTube thing and go you probably have
to go to like 1.25 instead of 1.5 and
you can watch it faster
if you don't have two hours to watch the
whole thing share it share with your
friends like right now like on YouTube
or wherever you're at if you're on
Twitch here's another way that I
monetize here's another way that I
monetize this show just to give you just
to be transparent about it
if you're on Twitch or if you don't have
twitch
but you have an Amazon Prime account
you can actually go and log into twitch
with your Amazon Prime account because
you get one free subscription a month
and it's not a lot just a few bucks it
literally is just a few dollars per
subscription
that I get as part because you logged in
with your Amazon Prime and you have to
renew it every month uh someone told me
you have to renew it every single month
I'm not really sure exactly how all that
works but that's another way so those
are the ways that I stay in front of
this microphone because it's my job it's
what I do now
it's what I do now
and I'm doing it
because I think that it needs to be done
someone has to do it
no one else is going to do it so I'm
going to and I want to be clear because
some people have said oh well we can't
get monetary support and some people
don't make enough money listen
I understand that that is why this show
right here this two hours hopefully
three hours very soon is absolutely free
you do not have to pay a single
dime to watch this show or to listen to
it on any directory if you want to
listen to it that is what is most
important to me
it's that you have a way because I don't
want to gate it behind you know uh um a
gate
now I have gated content on patreon that
I'm producing outside of the show for
the people who pay to be on patreon
because I feel like if they give you
know ten dollars twenty dollars fifty
dollars a hundred dollars I feel like
they should get more than just the show
so I have to I'm doing extra outside the
show
for those folks and those members over
on patreon
and I appreciate every single member on
patreon and I appreciate every single
person in the chat that isn't a member
on patreon I appreciate every single
person who listens to me that isn't in
the chat
I appreciate every single like
every single share we have grown this
show I just told you a while ago there
was 10 MJ said I think MJ didn't you say
10 people there were 10
listening 10 of us and I was probably
two of them because I had two windows
open just to make it look like I had 10.
and we've grown this show and you guys
you guys are the best audience in the
world and that's why I say that because
I truly believe it you guys come here
day after day after day after day
and you continue to come back
even the hate Watchers I love you guys
Don you're one of my favorites Christian
you're one of my favorites fake game
used to be one of my favorites till he
started being way too racist and I had
to block him
but that's how I make a living that's
how I do it so whatever support you can
give whether it's coming and sharing it
whether it's liking the YouTube video
whether it's going over to Twitch and
signing up with your Prime account to
get a subscription over there so I get a
few bucks rather it's going to patreon
and giving a few dollars
rather it's buying merch and getting a
really cool t-shirt with a cool design
and I get a piece of that that is how I
monetize that is how I quote stay in
business
because it's my job it's my job to sit
here and do this and I want to get to
something here speaking of my job I I
would be derelict at my duty today if I
did not show this video
um Mike sington um had this here but uh
Southpaw left us
um he says GOP and he's trying to say
this uh GOP look at these cherry-picked
detransition trans people who regret
their actions guess that means it should
be illegal
of course that's how they feel he says
the same on same GOP for these stories
crickets and what you're going to see
here this is the Buffalo Mass shooter in
a courtroom okay now I don't know if you
watch the video and I'm not going to
show that one because I don't have
enough time this is the more important
one but yesterday
oh Jesus
one of the fathers
of the victims that this
murdered because they were black
tried to go after him in the courtroom
be quite honest with you I don't
blame that Dad for wanting to kick this
asshole's teeth in
um
you with someone's kids you kill
someone's kids
that is um
that is almost unmanageable for another
human being so I don't necessarily blame
the father for what he did
um obviously he's probably going to be
charged for what he did and he'll
probably plead guilty because he's not
sorry that he did it but that that that
was shown that started to spread around
um social media yesterday where the
father was uh jumping towards the
Buffalo shooter here now this is the
Buffalo Shooters what I would call an
apology but it's not really an apology
but listen to the key words he says
I just showed you a clip where Tucker
Carlson is freaking out about Chelsea
Handler not wanting kids
um and I showed you a statement earlier
of the Cheeto dust q a because Tucker
Carlson Ben Shapiro Matt Walsh they all
incite violence
against trans people the lgbtq community
people of color
but there's no one better at it than the
Cheeto desk you and honor Donald Trump
himself Jesus Christ I just showed a
statement just showed a statement how
he's calling on the 2A Bros to do
something about the reverse racist
James the New York attorney general
she's black folks that's what he's
saying she's black
use your Second Amendment right
she's trying to take away from you
better use it on her before she stops
you
but listen to what the Buffalo Mass
shooter says here
about online rhetoric it's very
important a terrible thing that day I
shot and killed people because they were
black
Looking Back Now I can't believe I
actually did it
I believe the one I read online and
acted out of hey
no I can't take it back but I wish I
could
and I don't want anyone to be inspired
by me and what I did
hey Tucker
hey Tucker are you listening hey
Sean Hannity are you listening
hey all you megalodites out there Lauren
bobert
Marjorie Taylor green
you racist pieces of
are you listening to what he's saying
he listened to you
he took your words and he made action
because he thought that's what you
wanted
and now he regrets it and he can't take
it back he can't
and we won't let him take it back and
we're not gonna let you take it back
either
we are not gonna let yeah Kathy says
don't forget Alex Jones Jesus Christ if
I had to sit here and Kathy
thanks for helping me out there but man
if I had to sit here and list every
single one of these scumbags who who
promote and Stoke stochastic terrorism
at this point
Steve Bannon Mike Lindell
Mike Flynn
I mean the list goes on and on and on
and on and on and on every last
one of them if they got an R next to
their name
they inspired this do you
remember when uh Paul Pelosi Nancy
Pelosi's husband was smashed in the head
with a hammer
because of manga terrorist broke into
their home because of lies that the
right wing is telling him that he
believed online
and that demented lunatic little
went to act him out thought he would be
some kind of magahiro
listen to this one more time one more
time oh just listen to it one more time
it's beautiful it's beautiful the truth
the truth is something isn't it it's
something it's a terrible thing that day
a shot and killed people because they
were black
but getting back now I can't believe I
actually did it
I believe the one I read online and
acted out of hate
I know I can't take it back but I wish I
could
and I don't want anyone to be inspired
by me and what I did
there you go
that's why I do what I do every single
day
it's what I do that's why I do it
if I can if I can just convince
a thousand people
and then those thousand go talk to
another thousand and those thousand go
talk to another thousand another
thousand another thousand another
thousand I believe if I pound this drum
on this microphone
for the next 25 30 years
I believe I can do a service to this
country
by calling them out laying it out bare
showing them who or who the they
are don't like love it
do not
go easy on them
give them the strength of liberalism and
democracy
all in one Fell Swoop
we can do it we have to do it together
it can't just be me
because remember I only have one
microphone
your thousands of microphones
and I am so happy that you're here every
single weekday Monday through Friday
noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on
YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page also don't forget to go
follow us on the up wired YouTube
channel just go to upwire.com all links
are there go to upwire.com you find the
YouTube channel there don't forget to
subscribe with your Amazon Prime account
on Twitch it's free that's a free way to
support me
it really is if you've got an Amazon
Prime account that you're paying for
anyways and just go log into twitch and
you get you get one free subscription if
you do that
and you subscribe to my Channel with it
it doesn't cost you anything extra and I
get a couple it's a couple bucks I think
I don't know exactly how much it is
honestly it's just a couple bucks
a month it's a couple bucks a month but
it's a free for you it doesn't cost you
a goddamn thing if you're on Facebook
right now go follow me on Facebook after
you Johnny Michaels download every
single episode on Apple Spotify and
Google that's one of the best ways to
support me it doesn't give me money but
it gives us numbers it gives us data it
gets our voice out there more trust me
it does gets in that algorithms speaking
of algorithms go follow us on Twitter at
Tony Michaels pod we're going to put the
um the bonehead of the week pull out
early today probably in the next hour
I'm hoping we'll get the bonehead of the
week pull up and also do not forget to
subscribe here on YouTube before they
kick me off
before they shut me up
no it's important that you subscribe to
YouTube because that's how you're going
to vote for bonehead of the week too
it's on the community tab
every single week on the community tab
because tomorrow's Friday
and you know what Friday is bone end of
the week in the second hour don't forget
to watch tomorrow same time same place
Surf's Up you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
them
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn head ass Beacon